I came lifted up it's cool is about them
but the game has changed now Dominic
Toretto's just went rogue you're gonna
turn your back on family
I know it looks bad don't give up on
them fillies I've only got one chance to
make this family whole again okay that's
done really one thing I can guarantee no
one's ready for this
she's a very definition of itec
terrorism there's thousands of carton
any and now they're all night
now I know what it feels like to be
every cop ever taping us wait wait wait
[Music]
ah oh
London
Abu Dhabi Cuba our path of cross before
dawn needed to know it I think I need to
remind you why you chose to be here I've
got no choice
you gotta catch da you got me little
help
you want to tell me why you just put me
in a room with this game crumpet being
criminal nothing that factitious kind of
the circulation you're playing you
should get bigger size
you guys are going to work together left
I've been waiting for this we gotta
change
now mother Oh babies haha
[Music]
just don't give up here he thought this
was going to be a street fight
that's all right now click the wheel
what
wicked cranky ha ha alright you get
style points for that one
I don't know why you're doing this but I
know one thing you love me
[Music]
ah
you
[Music]
you